ladies and gentlemen this is an update
to the white hatch in your story if you
haven't seen it already you can go watch
it here
uh basically to summarize and ed tech
camp is using
thuggish tactics to take down any
criticism they deem
in any way negative of them at the same
time they try to pretend
that they're very accepting of criticism
i showed you guys that in the last video
of course it's colloquially known even i
was getting comments that
they take down stuff they love to do it
but what isn't known
is exactly how extensive this is right
so i'm here to tell you today
you remember those slack conversations
from last time that were leaked well
someone went through them and cataloged
all the links they were following
reporting
monitoring trying to get taken down and
they actually categorized it in a
gigantic spreadsheet
okay i'm not going to be sharing it on
screen because it contains private
information and i don't want to give
them
any false reason to take down this video
so i'm not going to be sharing that but
if you want to find it online you can
pretty easily find it but the point is
i went and i chased down all these links
and i checked
how many of them did they successfully
delete their whole case
remember is that they're only suing two
of their critics
for millions of dollars because they
lied they don't
they don't mind real criticism from real
customers that's what they say
right here's what we find in
actuality just in the month of october i
made it october so it's easy
to project out for the year they removed
109 posts they removed
51 youtube videos 51
they removed 27 twitter posts 11
facebook posts
15 linkedin posts three instagram posts
and two posts from the most unlikely
source of all
nine gag yes that's right white hat jr
is even monitoring
nine gag for offensive comments and they
go ahead and get those removed here here
are the
comments in question someone was making
fun of one of their uh you know success
stories that was a big joke
yeah they don't take too kindly to that
they get that stuff removed
and look you might be asking yourself
well stephen how do you know that this
is
this is a real list how do you know that
they really are taking them
down well the reason we know these are
real is that a lot of them
are especially the youtube videos in
particular are being manually taken down
with copyright strikes
right even when they don't have reasons
to take down content they'll take it
down anyways see this is one of the
comments for one of these youtubers
where they say
user has nowhere to use the white hat
junior logo or any copyrighted content
in the video so you can't copyright
strike
because that's how they're getting all
these videos done there's no legal point
with us to dispute with youtube on this
video
trademark certificate might help us to
take it down but when you go to the
video do you see taken down by a
trademark
no we see it's taken down by a copyright
claim from the same company that's
taking all of these white hat junior
things down it's one of their
corporations i guess they've even gone
so far as to get some youtube accounts
banned the account that posted it all of
a sudden gone
isn't that a coincidence i mean and can
we address the nine gag thing
guys let me say look there are a few
points in life where you got to stop
yourself right we talked about this when
the guy tried to escape from the fbi
with the c scooter i told you guys if
you ever find yourself on a c scooter
you know you've made a series of poor
life decisions you don't just end up on
a c-scooter the same is true here
if you find yourself monitoring and
censoring posts on 9gag
which is the platform people go to when
they haven't heard of reddit yet and
they're stuck in 2009.
when you find yourself doing that you've
taken some wrong turns
and what i want to say to the leadership
of white hat jr if i could speak to them
for a second
you guys are playing the victim and it's
not working it's clearly not working
these lawsuits have hugely backfired on
you people are now paying even more
attention to the topic than they were
before
and you're embarrassing yourselves
because look at this look at this this
is from the same post from the ceo where
he tries to play the victim
news cycles turned against us because
negative stories are far more
sensational than the truth
no dude the truth is look i didn't have
to sensationalize this
you sensationalized it the fact that 109
critical posts were removed in october
that's already a sensational fact and
you created the negativity for yourself
instead you're trying to pretend like oh
we didn't want to go to court but you
sued
oh false unethical attacks what's false
one of the main criticisms that wolf
gupta is a false
imaginary character you in your lawsuit
admit it is true so you're suing them
but they're right about their main
critical points so look again speaking
to
the leadership of white hat jr you guys
have to take a different path this isn't
going to work for you this
constant censorship instead you got to
drop the lawsuits stop the censorship
admit to messing up and call it a day
but this isn't going to work what i'm
seeing right here
taking down 100 posts a month how long
do you think you can keep doing that
until there's a thousand negative posts
a month i mean if there's one thing the
internet hates it's somebody trying to
shut down the internet and that's
exactly what you guys are doing here
no one's gonna stand for it and um yeah
i just wanted to chronicle this
uh i gotta just stop this video before
it gets to out of hand i made my point
so i don't know how long this video is
gonna be up so if you see it share it
uh thanks for watching and i'll see you
next time and don't forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you